ok next game will this Alex in the US is
red 2 215 let's get for something
different now planking for your cat oh
yeah
interesting place a samish set up
against this
a celeb played dumb when I to f6 our law
noclegi five I hope for him to play yes
exactly to get this one in with a gain
of tempo and now I also have this this
loose intermedia check here to capture
on edge sticks with the Queen to provoke
slight weakness yeah I just I just go
for something for the end game now or
endgames a little bit oh no the
statement the queenless middlin game
maybe but I think it should should be
okay for black I have a wide for black
page actually it's not not not a big
problem for white but I cups I got the
nice bishop on c 8 i've got rid of my
bed one on g7 i think one idea here for
wider is special page 3 just trying to
get rid of his bishop as well he doesn't
go for the idea okay i'm not i'm not
quite sure about f5 here because he
could he could take maybe and then go
for F for himself I'm not sure if it's a
good idea right away so certainly a
normal plan but hmm yeah but I don't see
how can make much progress without this
move so let's go for a five I wants to
exchange this night on c5 I think yeah
okay now I'll take here and gain the
temple
okay 93
yeah not much that I can do about this
maybe it's an idea to let him exchange
on c5 to get the B file
okay amazing
okay maybe I was worried that something
is going to G form it I don't think he
wants to really play G for this would be
would be a strange decision to say the
least
ya need to need to speed up here as
usual
takes on c5 I could also consider to
take with indie porn is his plane g4
amazing yeah okay what now g5
immediately and then aged Friday of
course this just killed the bishop
completely and i would say at the idea
of h5 after which he maybe he just
ignores everything okay
yeah okay I don't see they don't see
what he's doing he just needs he needs
to take here I think now otherwise i
wouldn't reform and then i get f 4 for
my night take here first and then
neither for with the gain of tempo also
hard to see how you could give defend
what is this so let's just lose the
bishop I think everyone is unprotected
light resigns yeah could just take no
here yeah this went downhill very
quickly oh he's asking me you play chess
cube yeah I do I guess he's also playing
a chess cute maybe we played there no
idea okay I'm just do a quick quick
recap here yeah I got a comfortable
position here but I think a white goes
for Bishop h3 here shouldn't shouldn't
be a huge problem for him because he's
getting rid of his mentorship as well
but he played this is this kind of
position is really without any good
prospects there for white you cannot
gain any space and it's already very
nice position for black but this this is
really really really bad I just I just
see here I also could have played night
h5 should have been a good move because
some it's hard to defend III yeah okay
it's a final position anyway